vegas golden knights is starting a  four-game road trip tonight in montreal  without another key player six of their  top players are nursing injuries right  now the latest william carlson he's out  several weeks with broken foot despite  this head coach pete deboer thinks the  knights can pull through  as a coach you want a little bit of  adversity i'm not sure you want it right  at the beginning of the season and we've  dealt with our share especially with  injuries here but i think we've come out  the other end of it and  you know the key is not to let the noise  affect you  the knights back on the road for their  next four games they start in toronto  taking on the maple leafs punk drops at  four o'clock